è vargas truffati aia ma porca eva il
tuo obiettivo è quello di arrivare al
lavoro in tempo e presto e 6
non ho capito camminare non è così
facile come ricordarvi fortuna talmente
stai portando una caffettiera piena di
caffè vorrà capite perché non bevo il
caffè perché le persone avevano caffè
sono tutte così dopo bere caffè per
rimanere sveglio un po che parlava bene
play adesso a sono questo qui io
buongiorno ma mi fate capire un attimo
come si deve bere caffè
come si vede il caffè forse come lo bevo
il caffè solo esportato come si fa
vedere come di caffè berica fertili no
non ho propriamente capito come si beve
il caffè in questa cosa però va bene io
devo correre bere caffè trovano alla
percentuale mi indica ok mi indica
quanto sto mi sto documentando quindi se
non sbagliarsi tasto magari una donna ma
dov'è a ok ho capito come si vede che ho
capito qual è il tasto porca scatola
schifosa laida devo andare a lavoro io
lo sai cosa aia barbone guida la
macchina invece di stare fuori guida di
mortacci tua
l'hack è male come ha fatto come si
cammina aia non mi passate sopra sono un
cittadino onesto io pago le tasse ai a
ce l'ha fatta
salve ma sotto anzi tutti anche lei po
di buonumore oggi al lavoro aia porca
eva non è possibile ma il problema che
non riescono non ti puoi girare
istantaneamente deve fare un giro strano
se hai un po di caffè che sono accorto
sono a corto di caffè ragazzi ci
potrebbe essere un problema di mortacci
mi ha permesso lavoro qui io lavoro qua
e giusto no non lavoro qua credevo di
lavorare qui mi stavo sbaglia l'hack è
male
mancano 13 secondi veloce zio aia
non riesco a muovermi evenienza continua
a tirare facciate susta vetrine non
riesco più a sfuggire ad ok è molto figo
se non si cioè non si capisce dove devo
andare proprio e molto fico sono forse
per questo proviamo ad attraversare la
high up la nostra la strada fronteras
alla strada voglio capire dove dovrebbe
essere mio lavoro aia li mortacci tua
sorella
i lati della strada no no ma sei scemo
se vedi una persona che file e investi
così l'hack è male pure sulla roccia
fermi tutti che devo capire allora 10
metri 8 metri 7 metri dal cantiere dove
che lavoro l'hack è male eccomi sono
questo l'obiettivo non mi dire che
dovevo toccare l'obiettivo sin da subito
sto male e questo la vogliono toccare
l'obiettivo
ma c'era arrivato anche prima solo otto
ore per prima di andarmene almeno posso
sedermi va bene re tra i trainer è solo
questo gioco ma come la un'ora di
scaricamento perché non ci ha messo
nella scaricarlo per solo aiac e dolore
per solo un gioco così cortona serio e
ma la sete stronzi sito stronzo sulla
targa ai a restar ma c'è solo una mappa
ma no ma fatene di più non sto
scherzando lo stato non fa neanche la
movenza libera il caffè lo beve mai ma
lei è un po manigold se glielo posso
dire va bene niente
questo è questo e quanto e stato bello
finchè è durato sul gioco avere nextgame
signori siamo sul secondo gioco di oggi
e stavolta vero non si era più duratura
stiamo subendo week che significa
maneggia con cura e non è quello che
state pensando ma che incredibile
opportunità per te essere il nuovo
trainer che non so cosa voglia dire
enormi 0 nel nostro usa il tuo lavoro e
mettere le ultime tre le reliquie
assegnate al loro posto vai adesso
direttore bene credo lavoro nel mese
inglesi e devo mettere le reliquie già è
complicato lavorare in un museo che è
storto perché estorto però prendo questa
è di e di sparta
questa è originale di pardo prometto
dove lei dove la metto questa cosa dove
devo ma perché l'hai presa che non sanno
dove mettere alla sua deve portarci la
piedi va bene ma l'hack è male ma non
contro la colonna girati girati girati
tirati o ciò che fai cadere i casi 3d
che no no va bene una colla era di
pietra di pietro e niente questo non era
di pietro come fate a rompersi la corona
mi chiama sono fatte di indivisibili di
cai di plastica ma the game
[Musica]
questo io lo devo mettere lì ho fatto
meno 500 punti sia ai delle gambe
veramente storte non so dove le imprese
porca vacca che no no no va beh
ok ok a posto c'è stato un problema di
non fa niente no no no premio premio
meglio proprio che non si può prendere
le cose stagioni a ci sono proprio solo
quelle tre cose da prendere ad altre
sono cose che dovrebbero dovrebbero
rimanere intatte ok
prendiamola la colonna la presa la metto
lì la metto il cammi three cammina
dritto per cortesia camia no cav ieri
porca vacca è non lo toccano gli
avvocati non gli ho toccato nella colpa
mia non avete visto tutti è niente volo
toccato invece ce la faccia non buttare
giù qualche ora è questo ciò che è
complicato
si gioca anche molto molto complicato
comunque vorrei messo a posto è per
carità di dio tutto bene ma anche
all'ultimo vaso che un antico l'antico
vaso andava portato in salvo questa
della dinastia ming
ora demonio
ma piano piano piano piano piano gaming
qua si incazza effetto il quadro non va
giù un quadro novaggio quindi puoi
passare vicino al quadro bravissimo
bravo l'antico vaso bravo ocio ciò che
il ragazzo in un fenomeno solo detto è
incredibile no no no non è caduto negato
l'accaduto ma dove va a cagare allora
non era accaduto per una volta che
l'accaduto niente meno 250 di punteggio
a game my time i clan
zam bus è la pizza la pazza la puzza
cioè fatemi capire se non messe non
giocavo facevo più pubblici va bene
complimenti ragazzi avete fatto un gioco
della madonna
questa era è handle with care capolavoro
videoludico moderno
let's go with terzo game di oggi siamo
su type che non è un simulatore di
quello che pensate
ma start ok questo dovrebbe durare di
più come gioco visto che ti fa anche
calibrare lo schermo denti più che
intyre deve essere un gioco sul sulle
biciclette io sono bravissime la cava un
sacco a si parte subito così va bene
allora mi fate capire un attimo come si
gioca sta roba
ok non sono morto non sono morto
meraviglioso e una è un grandissimo
traguardo per la mia vita
ve lo assicuro ragazzi non essere morto
in questo momento è tanta roba
come si pedala partiamo dalle basi più
incredibili come come e perché come
salti con la vicina lo spieghi tu non me
lo spieghi
va bene come si sa secondo me non si
salta così però ci stiamo lavorando per
carità ciao attivati rialzi proprio non
ti far ripartire al cippo in finissimo
stato sono una tipa va bene ride bene no
la vedevo troppo solo alla mia vice
allora ho deciso di farle compagnia
letto la colonna vertebrale ce l'hai la
colonna vertebrale non stavo mettendo in
dubbio
bene se a parti ho capito non ho capito
che si gioca avevo capito come si ci sia
a posto
va bene sono cose che succedono quando
andate a eccolo il salto su come saltare
senza bici vale qualcosa
ebbene no niente non so come saltare
neanche senza b è molto complicato
questo gioco va beh non puoi saltare
quindi della va bene sono per saltare
questa tensione molto bene mi è piaciuto
mi è piaciuto se lo possiamo rifare mi
fai felice se a rifarlo ritornare
innanzitutto la sopra che potrebbe
essere anche difficile spingi spingi
spingi spingi ok perfetto aggirati
girati girati gira gira e orca h
perfetto adesso vai let's go baby non ci
credo no mi sembra troppo bello per
essere vero sono spaccato per terra è
stato fighissimo
ma ma ho fatto una figata non so come ho
fatto però quello il problema però fatto
gesù gianni gitti cosa succede nel mondo
fermi che ho fatto
ora cavalca che male che male mi sono
fatto prima nodo ripartire porco demonio
allora allora allora no no che si scusa
storica vacca niente difficilissimo
regala maggiore difficilissimo non ce la
farò mai a fare una roba del genere
cadere dritto però ragazzi in sé per sé
il gioco è carino sono un po strano pò
tanto però non è male va bene ragazzi
questo era è stato inebriante c'è giuro
non ho mai giocato a niente di più
significativo per la mia persona in
credo che andrò mai in bici così tanto
però tre giochi uno più subito
dall'altro va proprio in escalation
questo è il 2018 dei videogiochi e non
me ne pento per niente anzi quelli
ragazzi spero capito che sia piaciuto
cosi mi piace anche questo giacomino
d'ottone descrizione fatemi sapere ciò
che voi andate così bene in bici
ricordatevi l'elemento che importante e
noi ci vediamo al prossimo video da
ragazzi
[Musica]